first of all I gotta say wow that is
some shirt feels pretty good to be out
here that is ending the number one
comedy in America that's a pretty cocky
thing to do I not many people have come
out wearing that shirt on such an
occasion
I got to give it to you thank you so
much I try to be the first that things
yeah like first place in comedy in
America yeah congratulations I I know
that's that's that's great I know that
you are the number one comedy in America
I didn't realize big country it's a big
country very big how did you guys do
overall like compared to other among
comedies yeah does a little whatever
were one among um Romani the only comedy
number one what about like compared to
like Beauty and the Beast and that was
that number that that movie I believe
was the number one comic movie turned
into a film movie in America right okay
yeah but you guys might be above us you
know overall uh-huh I don't know I don't
I doubt it
what about that movie life didn't that
movie life come out ya know number one
space movie in America yeah yes what
would have Power Rangers be then yeah
Oh number 1 Power Rangers movie out in
America any Power Rangers bells
[Applause]
clearly number one you could say you
could say that we came in six or seven
right you could say that that's a number
you could focus on sure or you could
focus on the number one movie in America
comedy in America right yeah let me tell
you they seem to agree with you this is
definitely the way to go
yeah yeah yeah well I think it's the
only way to go I don't think I could
have gone the other way
uh-huh uh-huh this is what how I look at
it when you're in high school you and
your sweetheart for the first time you
have sex you're terrible right you're
the worst
right but also you're the best she's
ever had you know time yeah you feel me
yeah didn't happen in high school for me
I mean you're high no other way graduate
graduate school and I'm jumping right at
doctoral degrees yeah 1998 anyway the
point is you and your 42 year old
sweetheart I'm still the best ever after
a very early dinner at Denny's
you